there's a rumor that you once did a
porno movie thank you I was in a porno I
didn't have sex in a porno I was just an
actor in a porno it was a parody of a
British game show called stars in their
eyes I don't know if I can say the title
but it's something in their eyes you can
figure out the word yes and that was
what we change it to and I was just a
game show host and basically what they
did was they got celebrity look-alikes
to come out and have sex and so they had
one girl was like three so they're
having sex in front of your character
well I well I my script ran out right
before the sex and then you just try to
keep yourself busy in the background
this is your acting take away
they're all everyone's having fun now
I get I get an erection well which aim
of Google having say Oh in real life
here you do luck and I'm wearing a suit
I never wear a suit and I get an
erection and even on the set of a pawn
my erection seems offensive to everyone
else and I'm wearing a suit I never wear
suit so I'm sort of tented out to the
Sun and I don't know I know how to get
rid of an erection in this outfit right
you reach in you pull up into the belt
pop only thing no erection right it's
what we all do
[Applause]
what we're both doing now but in a suit
like you're a suit-wearing guy and the
shirts tucked in yes you pull it up and
then the head of your penises it's just
over the top of the belt like like a
small tumor or a large tumor as it may
my my my sons oh I talk about all the
time on this show yeah hey
my girlfriend's obsessed with the look
of his penis in that weird like he's got
a little baby penis because he's aren't
not even two yet and she doesn't think
it looks very good so she started
googling baby penises but on my computer
and it's hard but when the cops show up
for me to go I just wanted to see a nice
one Computers still just well she's
worried because when he urinates it goes
off to the side and she thinks that it's
crooked and I'm like no that's what
happens if I just stood there like this
would just go everywhere he hasn't
learned the power of direction yeah it's
like a fire hose that no one's holding
on very small fire hose yes yeah okay
let's leave children out of this and get
back to you on the set of the porn okay
now what are you really doing I can't
imagine being there while people are
really having sex and you're just
standing there in the end you're you're
a comedian you're not a porn at the end
why the time I was young I needed the
money I got 500 pounds which I thought
was a lot of money but then I found out
that the girl who was doing the Paul
McCartney thing was getting 300 I felt
better about myself and so I do let's
not refer to anal sex anymore as the
Paul McCartney just out of respect to
Sir Paul McCartney he's I think he's
achieved enough that we should he hasn't
earned that it just turns out that you
can buy me love anyway so I'm sitting
there in a chair and they're having sex
I'm just trying to keep you know focused
I'm not having an erection yeah and then
they yell cut and the the guy who's
wearing a hockey mask going to tell you
one of them's dressed as Eminem in the
ice hockey mask or the chainsaw wait
it's Emma it's an Eminem look-alike
having sex with Britney Spears why
aren't you following this anyway so they
do cut and the guy has to still say stay
hard is that we like to say that we I
guess you said bob says you just said
bob you've committed so many greater
crimes already and now you're like
excuse me before I proceed
is it okay so anyway he comes in
standing next to me and he's keeping
himself hard at my eye level whilst
right and I'm just sitting there going
oh no this isn't how I wanted my life to
turn out yeah and he looks down at me he
goes I won't do the motion he goes oh
hey Jim how did you get into comedy and
I went oh you know standard sort of
thing went and did some Open Mic suffer
around the clubs around Perth Australia
and he goes I don't know how you do that
mate that's got to be the hardest
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you